We have a screwed up daughter
she has no friends
she has no confidence , he's mine you know
Maria
let me help you
let me be there for you
self improvement
it's a jungle out there
are you sure you wanna go to school looking like that? What?
I really didn't mean to do that
Maria
who are you , Don't you remember me?
we have a screwed up daughter
she has no friends
he's mine ya know
she has no confidence
this is your time to shine
I can fix things
let me help you
Trust me
let me be there for you
Instead of you , Morning ice queen
what?
am I not fun anymore
hi dad
You're dead
why are you doing this?
self improvement
I'm sorry, I'm not
that they've sent
it's time they learned about
look at me
see me